Hey Beth!
Hello!
Good to see you!
How are you?
I am so excited to record another podcast with you.
Always fun.
Yes, those are always the best days.
Yeah.
I thought today I would talk about distance transforms.
Mmm, I like it.
Yeah, so yeah, I'm just going to dive right in.
Yeah, we haven't had very many like in the weeds,
Matthew ones lately, which I assume is not terribly Matthew.
No, this is me doing this.
This is not you doing distance transforms.
Then we might get real Matthew.
I like that is, yeah, no, this is, I mean,
I will show a little bit of math,
but this is more of a conceptual,
what even is this thing and how do I use it?
Because there have definitely been some pipelines
that we've used where it's been super duper helpful.
And every single time I've used a distance transform,
I have to stop and look at the images
and think through what I'm doing.
So I thought I would do that, like stop,
look at the images and think through them out loud.
Absolutely.
Hopefully bring some people along with me.
No, that wasn't as a bad thing.
Just we've been talking a lot about soft skills lately,
which is great.
Soft skills are a huge part of this job,
but it's good to get into some nitty gritty pipeline making.
Yeah, so this is definitely some nitty gritty.
So yeah, we're just going to dive right in here.
What I have is a set of images that we'll see as we move along.
Pretty simple and very simple pipeline here,
if you're wanting to try it on your own,
where I'm just using the name of this image to match.
I just have these four images so I can load them all in at once.
This does not represent anything you would do biology-wise.
This is just get them into a pipeline so we can use them.
So yeah, let's just do a distance transform
and see what happens.
So here, what I have is I've input,
this is my image that I have distance transformed.
And so here I have background in black and foreground in white.
And what this distance transform is doing
is telling me how far away is this part of my foreground
from background.
So if I'm hovering, you see me hover on my image here
and below in the task bar, it's telling me intensity.
So that's yes, thank you for the annotation.
So here in intensity, if I'm hovering around the area that
started as my background, my background is 0 pixels away
from my background.
So background doesn't change here.
But we can see the number gets larger
as I get further and further away from background
within my foreground, what was my foreground area.
And these numbers-
Needed to be pinker.
Absolutely.
The number is going up to, well, here,
391 is the closest I can hover here
because that is how far away this pixel, like the farthest
pixel away in this foreground from this background.
So that's a distance transform.
That's what it's doing.
That's it.
And it's a measurement in pixels.
We're not, because we're in superfile,
we're not talking about real distances.
Nope, nope.
Yep, this is just straight up pixels.
We are counting pixels here.
So we can look then at another example
just to get another little bit of intuition, where, again,
I'm looking at just in my foreground how far away
is a point from background.
So again, if I hover all around in my background,
intensity is still 0 because my background is my background,
therefore 0 pixels away from my background.
If I go into what was foreground here,
the furthest away, this 71 pixels, I think,
the most it can get away.
So this interior, this spot, that is the furthest away,
it can get from a background.
And as I get closer to the edge of my foreground,
those numbers go down until I get to my background again.
And so that's what it looks like when
we have these different shape structures.
It's really funny to me because in the first image,
I have a hard time saying, like, why would I
want to see how far I am from the black part?
Like, why would that matter?
And then as soon as it looks kind of vaguely biological,
I'm like, oh, because the white part is foreground
and the black part is background.
OK, I totally see why this is important now.
Yeah.
So then to even get into what's an example of what
we might do this, I have made just
so you can see the difference in the way we might measure things.
I've inverted it.
So I've made an inverted version of this image.
And I also calculate a distance transform here.
So again, we get kind of a funny looking thing.
Like, this is not what you would usually
think for biological objects.
But hold this thought because this can answer
different questions for us.
But here, because this is showing us, again,
this is foreground and how far away is it from background.
So here, I have a spots.
Brought it in as an image that I'm making it into objects
and these large structures I'm making into objects.
Then what I want to do here is for my spots,
I am going to make measurements of the distance transform
of those large images and the distance transform
of the invert of the large images.
So I've made some measurements.
OK.
And now, let's go to the workspace viewer
now that we've measured some things to actually look
at how this helps us.
So, you know, cooking shows dial.
Oh, god, me too.
It's so good.
I'm going to sort of pre-populated some things here.
So I put here in our inverted image
that we did the distance transform on.
And I'm showing you as a reminder,
this is where our large structures were.
So you can see those in the image.
And this is where the spots are, these green spots.
So if we look at intensity values in the distance transform
of these spots, it will tell us distances
and from these large structures, which if you think like biology,
there are many applications where you might have two sets
of structures and want to know information about how some of them
are related to other ones.
So here, the max intensity of this, ah, sorry,
that was not the inverted one.
I was like, those numbers don't look right,
because they're not.
We want the inverted.
Yes.
The measurement's made in the inverted image.
There we go.
So what we can see is max intensity
is telling us the farthest most point of this object,
how far away is it possibly from the big objects.
So here, in this one that is mostly overlapping,
the farthest away point of my spot is 23 pixels.
So you can see we can measure here to here is roughly 23 pixels.
Well, not roughly.
It's exactly 23 pixels, but my little.
My drawing was rough.
Yeah.
So this is 23 pixels away from here.
This one is 215 pixels away at its further most point.
And this one, this distance here, is 65 pixels away.
So this can also tell you, I guess
I don't have a great example in here,
but this can also tell you relationships,
whether so if this one was entirely in this spot.
Yeah.
You do have it.
Just do the other distance transform.
So right now we're looking at the inverted one.
Let's look at the other one.
The original transform.
Yeah.
So if we then go to the original one and see that instead,
so we can then look at so this measurement.
Now let's show you the spots.
Intensity, the maximum intensity of the distance transform
large.
Voila.
So I just clicked the delete button.
That wasn't what I meant to do.
I meant to click the font button.
Come on, Erin.
It's good to have repetition and show more than once.
Yeah.
So just there we go.
So you can see if we're making the measurement from the background
in relationship to the background,
it's telling us about relationships here,
where this maximum intensity is 0,
because it is not actually in this object at all.
Either of the objects in this category,
whereas these objects you can see have 67 pixels of that object
sticking at most distance in and here 12 at most distance in.
So depending on quite how you want to ask the question,
you can look at one distance transform versus the other.
Measurements made of the distance transforms versus the other.
Yeah.
Are you going to talk about some particular use cases
because I have some?
Yeah.
So I have one example use case here that is from a pipeline
that I have an actual real pipeline
that I have done on real data, not just silly black and white
objects, but here if we look here.
So this was a set of images that were stitched together.
And this represents the edge of the images
as they were stitched together on a black background.
So here this intensity of 0 is a true, there's nothing there.
The no pixels exist because I didn't have an image that
was stitched together.
And so this is kind of like I've zoomed in here
on the edge of a well.
You can picture a whole well of images stitched together
and a part that wasn't part of my acquisition is blank.
And so I've then identified nuclei in here.
And you can see as we hover over what
is background area from an image,
there is some intensity because of microscope offset
and all that.
Your background is rarely ever truly zero in an actual image.
But it is truly zero when I am hovering over here
in the background of my stitch.
So I then do a threshold where I'm saying, OK,
because I know that my background is truly zero
and something that came from an image is nonz,
it is bigger than zero.
I've just set this threshold to say anything
bigger than a very tiny number is my foreground
and this is my background.
Then we can do a distance transform and say,
how far away is anything here, like anything
in my foreground from my background?
And then measure the object intensity of the nuclei
in this image.
So these population statistics aren't very helpful.
But if we go look at nuclei in my,
if we plot it on the image itself,
then look at some actual numbers,
then we can say nuclei, intensity,
and look at the max intensity of the distance transform.
So this can be really helpful, especially in situations
where in this task, we really wanted
to know how close it was to this edge of the stitched image,
how far away any nucleus was, because there were artifacts
that were coming in from this being so close
to a physical well edge.
There was plastic right here that was doing funny things
to the light and so we wanted to be able to filter out
nuclei that were a certain given distance
from any actual edge and this was an easy way to do it.
So if we zoom in here, these are,
oh, when I'm hovering it's showing me,
the hover is not going to help, we want the numbers.
And there we go.
And so here it's telling us the number of pixels away
from that edge and smaller numbers over here.
This is a really large image, but you can see
like the further away you get, the larger the numbers get.
And if I go back to the whole image here,
how this set of numbers is then very different
from what we have here in the thousands
of our furthermost nuclei.
So we were then able to pick some number
that very easily gave us that cut off of,
I don't actually measure or proceed with any nuclei
that were too close to this edge
because there was a known artifact there.
So that's one of my like-
And we were able to do that later.
So we could try to keep them in if we wanted,
but then like iteratively like just change that line
in the pipeline that would have taken forever
to figure out what's the exact right cut off,
but by just making it a measurement,
you could figure it out later.
Yes, so absolutely one could take this image and say,
I'm going to mask out, I could threshold,
invert it and then expand my mask
to sort of mask out a step, stair step around here.
But to Beth's point, like, so we could do that,
this, just mask out a chunk along the edge.
But by doing it as a measurement,
we could experiment computationally later
and figure out what really was the best balance
of keeping the most cells while still removing
the ones that were having the most artifacts.
And we didn't have to pick a single number
in our pipeline and be stuck with it.
I think one that's nice for the one that you showed before
where the objects were partially,
like the sponsors partially overlapping
with the large objects also is,
we see people use these sorts of things a lot in tissue.
I have a big piece of tissue
and I have a big structure over here.
I've got a blood vessel and I wanna say,
how far are my cancer cells from the blood vessel?
CellProfiler has a measure object neighbors module,
which you can definitely also use for that,
but that gives you center to center distances.
What this will give you is your choice
of center to center or edge to edge.
And so we see lots of people doing this
for tissue measurements or other things
where it's like, I know I have certain classes of structure
and I wanna know like very specific information
about the relationships between them.
Yes, yeah.
Yeah, I think that's a great point, Beth.
Super great example.
And interesting to think of the same tool being used both.
I mean, as you mentioned,
like mine was about getting rid of artifacts
and your example was exploring very specific
relationships and biology.
And so kind of cool thinking the same tool,
the same little bit of math
and having a really wide range of applications.
Yeah, it's definitely one of my favorite tricks
to pull out for just sort of like figuring out
how close things are to each other.
And I think an underutilized one.
Yeah, yeah.
And again, one that I think is so much easier
to understand when you actually look at it.
So again, like yay workspace viewer
and yay for having a GUI for a CellProfiler
where we can actually see every single piece,
every image and picture what the measurements made
would look like on that image
to make sure we really understanding
what should I be doing this measurement in the,
you know, original distance transform
or do I want to invert my image
and then do a distance transform?
And you know, if you just ask me that,
I have to really reason my way through carefully
when you just show me a picture and I'm like, yeah, got it.
Oh yeah, I would have to check every time.
So, no, being able to just,
and that's the great thing with image analysis, right?
Like it's not like a Western blot we've used our sample
and it's gone forever.
Like we can just try a bunch of stuff
and then like figure out the right way to go forward.
Yes, yeah.
Well, and thank you not just to the creators
of self-referring the workstation viewer,
but thank you to you
for creating such a lovely demonstration case.
Yeah, my pleasure.
Thanks for joining me.
Yeah, thank you for such a fun, again,
I love the distance transform.
So this episode was great.
I'm glad you love it.
I am working on loving it.
But I think that, you know, understanding it
helps a long way towards loving it.
So.
Agreed.
Yeah.
All right.
Bye.